هذا هو اول ظهور للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين بعد اختفائه لاكثر من اسبوع ما اشعل
سلسله من الاشاعات حول صحته الرئيس الروسي
ظهر وهو يجتمع مع رئيس المحكمه العليا
وكان يبدو شاحبا اثناء اللقاء المتعلق
بالاصلاحات
القانونيه تصرف الكرملن اشعل الاشاعات حيث
تم الغاء اجتماعات رئاسيه مهمه في الايام
الماضيه هذه الفعاليه تم عرضها في يوم
المراه في الثامن من مارس اذار لتبديد بعض
المخاوف لكن تبين انها سجلت سابقا ما اثار
المزيد من الشكوك مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ازدحمت بتكه هنات ان بوتين مصاب بالسرطان
او انه تعرض لسكته دماغيه لكن الكرملين
نفى ذلك قائلا ان الرئيس يعمل من منزله
وهو بصحه
مثاليه لكن هذه اوقات عصيبه في موسكو
فالاقتصاد في تدهور والحرب في اوكرانيا
وترت العلاقات الدوليه واغتيال رئيس
المعارضه بورس نيمتسوف الشهر الماضي اثار
الاضطراب بين النخبه الروسيه والرئيس
المختفي يثير نظريات مؤامره
غامضه ونشر مستشار سابق لبوتن مدونه اشار
فيها الى ان الكرملن اطاح الرئيس في
انقلاب ولا يوجد دليل على ذلك لكن مع غياب
الرئيس عن نظر العامه حتى ان كان ذلك
لبضعه ايام فان الاشاعات تنتشر بسرعه اكبر
من امكانيه
احتوائها